foreign
if you're 42 years old or younger you
can freeze eggs
might meet someone later and decide you
want to conceive children or use a donor
after 42 I think it's at 42 and a half
you can only
create embryos and freeze those they're
just not the eggs are on average are
just too aged out
males if you want to be a sperm donor
you know ideally you're going to do that
before 45 sperm donor or you might want
to do IVF someday now there is a
significant increase in the incidence of
autism with each half decade for the
father you know so as you go from you
know 30 to 35 to 40.
the sperm age matters but
the increases
still incredibly small overall so it's
not something you can really point to
and say oh it's the sperm you know or
it's the egg for that matter okay now
do's and don'ts we can now easily look
back to the beginning of our discussion
it's very clear that quality sleep on a
regular basis sunlight keeping stress in
check healthy relationships over all of
that is going to support sperm health
and egg health no question about that
it's also clear that getting sufficient
omega-3 fatty acids is going to support
sperm health and neck Health I'll just
point out that if there were One
supplement that really seems to move the
needle in terms of egg quality which is
a morphological but also a meaningful
physiological metric or and sperm
quality which is going to be shape
motility you don't want what are called
Dead sperm they're always going to be
some in a sample because of the age of
the sperm Etc and the way the
spermatogens the cycle go but you want
forwardly motile sperm the other ones
are called twitchers so you know they
just Twitch in place
they can actually take twitchers and
force them into the egg during IVF
something called ixy but
in general the greater number of forward
motile sperm I'm swimming them towards
India yeah yeah I'm actually swimming
them an angle away from Tim so forward
on our first person podcast exactly can
be greatly increased by supplementation
with L-Carnitine so egg health and sperm
Health greatly enhanced by L-Carnitine
pretty remarkable results there
injectable L-Carnitine of about one mil
one Mig per day okay that has to be
prescribed by a doctor and that's I am
that's intramuscular yeah or oral
capsules are available over the counter
then you have to get up to four or five
grams per day wow yeah and that could
increase tmao and some other markers
that aren't great for cardiovascular
health because of the way it's processed
by the gut but you can offset that by
taking 600 milligrams of garlic because
of the allicin and garlic okay smoking
cigarettes vaping cigarettes really good
for sperm terrible for sperm terrible
for eggs smoking cannabis vaping
cannabis also terrible eggs and sperm
people don't like to hear that 15 of
women I can't believe the statistic but
I've seen it over and over and to check
my eyes but 15 ingest cannabis at some
point during pregnancy 15 probably not a
good idea now a lot of people say oh I
smoke weed every day and got my wife
pregnant
you never know how healthy your children
would have been you never you just never
know I'm not saying your children are
unhealthy but you never are also going
to be there will always be edge cases
where like I smoke crack every week and
never slept for 14 days straight my kids
are great and you're like okay just
because you happen to be the one mutant
right right right yeah if you want to
optimize for who can thread that needle
exactly it doesn't mean you're a good
model exactly so L-Carnitine can really
help avoid smoking anything
you know the issue of tinctures and
Edibles is a different subject
altogether
I think the big wow
for me was something again I'm just
gonna
tip my hat to you which is that in 2015
I taught a class at I was in a professor
at UC San Diego on neural circuits and
health and disease and I decided to do a
lecture on whether or not cell phones
inhibit sperm health and or testosterone
level
the data were very mixed frankly there
were essentially two good studies in
rats each of them taking a standard
smartphone putting it under a rat's cage
and then looking at some metrics related
to testicular Health sperm Health Etc
one showed increases in testosterone the
other show decreases so it was kind of a
disappointing situation so I would
present both
now there is an extensive meta-analysis
I can send you this for the for the show
notes if you like an extensive
meta-analysis of dozens of studies I'll
add it to the next reprint for our body
and it very convincingly shows that
keeping the cell phone in one's pocket
so this isn't putting it to your head
this isn't putting on the desk in front
of you but keeping it on and in one's
pocket
and it does not matter if it's on Wi-Fi
or you're using seller
decreases sperm quality which means
forward motility number of healthy sperm
per ejaculate Etc even ejaculate volume
to some extent and lowers testosterone
overall which is perhaps not surprising
giving the known heat effects of the
phone so even though it doesn't feel hot
to the touch there are heat effects
sperm don't like heat in fact the most
promising male contraceptive that's out
there that's not a condom is a it's like
a cuff that goes around the vas deferens
which is the portal from the testes to
the urethra that allows the ejaculate to
leave the body that heats that right I
mean asano will it's not a great form of
contraception because it's not sure
proof but it will reduce your total
number of motels born by 75 or so
when I go in the sauna because when I do
hope to concede children somewhere so I
wear shorts into the sauna and I
actually put a a cold pack at my groin
yeah while I'm in there it's actually
when the sun is really hot it's also it
makes it a little less unpleasant it's a
little painful but you definitely don't
want to do that on bare skin I'm
chuckling too but
heat is part of the problem with the
cell phone but it turns out yes and here
people are gonna think I'm a crazy
person but they might think that already
the emfs that business is real yeah now
is it so real that it's giving us
gliomas unclear I'm not gonna go there
the data aren't in but it is very clear
that the radiation from phones the emfs
and the heat are combining to reduce
sperm quality motility and overall
testosterone so it's a simple thing turn
off your phone completely
or even better just don't put it in your
front pocket if you have to put in a
pocket but in your back pocket if you
even better would be to put it in a
shoulder pocket or a backpack
and I also I'm a weirdo perhaps but I
don't like keeping the phone to the my
head too long but that's also because I
don't like holding onto my Edge for too
long we don't know very much about the
effects of EMS and heat effects on the
different tissues of the body but we now
know a lot about the effects of heat and
emfs on sperm
quality and it's not a good picture for
the sperm where does airplane mode
fit into this equation if at all in
terms of between on and off I mean does
it
prevent or mitigate some of the effects
it seems to yeah it seems to here's
what's really scary about this
meta-analysis their conclusion is that
the total amount of time spent with the
phone in the pocket is not a strong
determinant that it's it's not all or
none but that the threshold Beyond which
you start seeing these damaging effects
is pretty low so you know again here
we're talking about a don't not a do and
so it's pretty straightforward you know
don't keep the phone in your front
pocket if you're concerned with sperm
health and testosterone production now
why is sperm health and testosterone
production so correlated and you say
well duh it's because you know
testosterone and sperm but if you're not
interested in conceiving children you
might not think this is an issue but
remember that the two types of cells
those lidic cells and the sertoli cells
of the of the testes combine
testosterone in the Androgen binding
protein to give rise to sperm so anytime
you're seeing a reduction in sperm you
are definitely seeing that as a
reflection of reduction in Androgen
binding protein which means whatever
testosterone you have around is also not
having the effect on that local organ
that it should in other words the testes
and the ovaries are very interesting
organs because they secrete hormones
into the body to go have effects but
they also have effects on themselves and
it's self-amplify yeah and so this just
seems like such a straightforward one to
me and you said this back in when was
the four hour body published came out in
2010 yeah yeah and I remember you and
poliquin and a few other people saying
like don't keep the phone in your pocket
and I remember lecturing to about 400
students about this and I would say
about half just you know
by my read about half of the the guys in
the class took the phone out of their
pocket when they heard this
I think young people who aren't thinking
about having children at all right now
are absolutely the ones that should be
most concerned yeah yeah it is true you
can as they told us in high school it
just takes one sperm but you know just
takes one sperm but in order to get that
one sperm to the egg in Vivo you know
not IVF but it's called natural
conception
there's a lot of territory that needs to
be covered there's a lot of chemical
environments that need to be dealt with
you want the healthiest sperm so I would
say also having gone through this
process with an X to create embryos
even though you can say it only takes
one sperm in IVF as well you want to
Stack the odds in your favor which means
you need good morphology good motility
and you need a good count
of non-crippled sperm yeah sperm
analysis can be a humbling thing because
you know no matter what no one's getting
100 motile forward limo tile everyone
males and females learn a lot about
their biology what they're doing well
what they're doing less well when going
down that pathway of IVF I think I think
for women one of the big surprises is
that it doesn't take much ingestion of
alcohol to diminish egg quality you know
Beyond two or three drinks per week per
week
you really start to see reductions
inequality that are probably indirect
through effects on diminished sleep
and changes in stress hormones and so
you know again some people will be more
resilient to this than others people
always like to make jokes about how
alcohol facilitates the conception
process you know Etc you know I think
that in general you know if women are
having very regular Cycles whether or
not they're 28 days long or 35 days long
is less important perhaps and maybe
fairly regular women in general tend to
know more about their bodies and because
they cycle than than men but I if I
could go back in time to my 30s I sure
sure would have Bank sperm then yeah and
you know I feel good about where I've
gotten my parameters but it's really
interesting as you learn this you just
realize that
freezing sperm freezing eggs is a great
idea and freezing embryos makes sense if
you have the appropriate pairing or
situation right yeah and that life gets
so much easier for those wishing to
conceive when you have healthy embryos
Frozen in the bank yeah anyway for those
challenged in that area it also becomes
this like incredibly expensive
emotionally and financially expensive
battle